we are talking about automating
engineering of nanomaterials
how hard is this problem
and as we continue down this thread of
the positives
and the worrisome
what are the things we should be excited
about
and what are the things we should be
terrified about and how do we minimize
the chance of the
of the uh terrifying consequences
so in this robot the robot does all the
heavy lifting so the robot basically
is an embodied ai i really i really like
ai in in a domain specific way
one that actually should say at this
point there was an attempt in the 60s
uh joshua ludenberg and some really
important people who did this that made
an ai to try and guess if organic
molecules in the mass spectrometer were
alien or not
yes
and they did they failed because they
didn't have assembly theory
what does assembly theory give you about
alien versus human life well no it just
they it tells you about unknown the
degree of unknowns you can fingerprint
stuff they weren't looking at um they
were trying to basically just look at
the corpus of
or complex organic molecules
so i when i was a bit down about
assembly theory because i couldn't
couldn't convince referees and couldn't
convince computational
um
people interested in computational
complexity i was really quite depressed
about it and i mean i've been working
with with sarah walker's team
and she i think she you know i think she
also invented an assembly theory in some
way we can talk about it later
when i found the ai
not working for
the dendral project
i suddenly realized i wasn't it totally
insane
coming back to this nano
robot so what it does it's a basically
like a computer but now what it does is
it squirts
a liquid with gold in it in a test tube
and it adds
um some
uh reducing agents there's some
electrons to make the gold turn into a
nanoparticle now when gold becomes a
nanoparticle it gets a characteristic
color a plasmon so it's a bit like if
you look at the sheen on a gold wedding
ring or a gold bar or something those
those are the ways that conducting
electrons basically reflect light
what we did is we randomly squirt the
gold the gold particle and the reducing
agent in and we measure the uv we
measure the color and so what we do is
we've got the robot has a mind so it has
a mind where
in a simulation
it randomly generates nanoparticles and
the plasmon the color that comes out
randomly generally imagines in its head
it then with the other so that's the
imaginary side of the robot in the
physical side of the robot it squirts in
the chemicals and looks at the color and
it uses a genetic algorithm and a map
elite actually on it and it goes around
in cycles and refines
the color to the objective
now we use two different points we have
an exploration
and an optimization they're two
different so the exploration just says
just do random stuff and see how many
different things you can get and when
you get different things try and
optimize and make the peak sharper
sharper sharper
and what it does after a number of
cycles is it physically takes a sample
of the optimized nano material
resets all the the round bottom flasks
cleans them and puts the seed physical
seed back in
and what this robot is able to do is is
search a space of 10 to the 23 possible
reactions
in just a thousand experiments in three
days
and it makes five generations of
nanoparticles which get nicer and nicer
in terms of shape and color and
definition and then at the end it
outputs like ideal code
that can then be complete wow just doing
the search
for programs in the physical space yeah
so it's doing a kind of reinforcement
learning yeah yeah in the physical space
with the exploration and the
optimization and that idea will work on
any computer or any qualified hub now
that's it that's now that's a general
piece of code that can
replicate uh somewhat maybe perfectly
what it created that's amazing that's
incredible but the nanoparticles
themselves are dumb the robot has all
the thinking so we don't try and apply
any rep self-replication or try and get
the
the the particles to make themselves
although it would be cool to try
you